welcome to this video I'm playing Zachry
240 from dominic and public wow ok I
wanted to try the Dutch now I get some
very weird Dutch flavored stone type of
gambit funny opening okay how do I play
that may be okay maybe I can't ignore it
and just develop stuff I go h 6 ER ki h
6 is very weakening probably not a good
idea
okay you're going to play every move
instantly right it's always it always it
never ceases to amaze me okay what about
and the sisters very much looks like an
e4 e5 opening of course d 5 may be
interesting
what do a key position
yeah d 6 this kind of stuff maybe bishop
should be here with the tempo trying to
try to be quick here in development can
also casts a long maybe I should have
taken actually wants it to check yeah I
don't know I give up here I don't know
what this guys doing I don't ever he
never ever plays a move that I do expect
or anything but I have been or pieces
and play my king is not so insecure
check
or to e6 was also not a bad square
trying to get you five exchanged
okay I'll do how to punish all this
knight on d5 check coming out
they're just get clear the way to be
eight
yeah okay it's trying to do some sort of
a techie em but I don't really I don't
really think there's anything going on
trying to keep it simple exchanging some
stuff
but it was quick i mean i didn't
understand any move but it was quick
quickly played
okay we got into an endgame forgotten to
an end game and I like my chance to see
em time morning I have all the time in
the world to win one of those weaknesses
uh yeah sure I can win any of those
pawns at will okay let's let's grab the
dip on check check now that wasn't the
easiest way to play
what the heck did i do in this game
again I mean it should be over long ago
check that's actually quite lucky he
does not have a check in the solution
check check check let's meet next move
but what the heck did I shall dealt yeah
okay I admit it I got really pissed off
at this I mean he play dashed out all
this roofs instantly that offered the
draw and it totally lost position and so
on so it didn't really pay much
attention but it was really a bad play
of course I should just prevent all the
counterclaim I can for example just
chase and that's it just grab all the
parts yeah very very weird game or no
this is simply a non-existent Gambetti
form but maybe I mean you can play all
kinds of stuff against this F pawn moves
that is not totally bonkers maybe I
should just take the pawn but there is
definitely some risk okay here I thought
you would play d5 when there was
actually a bit concerned that this could
be quite good for what with this 96
possibilities coming could be really
good but he played this immediately of
course immediately just like it's the
third move or move in the Royal yam and
of course it's it's as much to do to
improve upon I'd be fire seems to be bad
c3 is strong here but I thought Bishop
g4 maybe but he really has this move and
I don't have a good square for the night
I really don't yeah this was very good
but he played this in five seconds
Bishop c5 I don't know but this clicking
move was probably necessary here and
here maybe I should just take I mean I
was check thinking about this but this
is good okay okay i kim this is good for
white so this was okay well d 6 is just
bad five seconds five seconds for that
I'll take it it's no compensation
whatsoever and this is not a clear
position at all I mean can't play all
kinds of stuff okay just take it this
miss blazes pieces and around here it
should be a game that should end in a
couple of moves because he has nothing
developed and is totally uncoordinated I
obviously played it like a [ __ ] ok
Vania want to get a quick moving there
should be two hours winning immediately
the rook has no squares I mean it's just
like I'm playing with all pieces for
going to and I'm just an exchange up for
nothing ok chess the first the first one
b5 is also better this this actually
gives up some advantage 92 now wins I
mean ok I always had a pretty clear but
it felt like it should have been been
over long before ok well thanks for
watching